[Music]
for your child there is no cure the
words that no parent wants to hear those
were the words the doctor said about my
little nephew in at age four Ian went
suddenly from being his normal sunshine
energetic self to being sick in a
hospital holding on to his teddy bear
and holding on for life the doctor said
it was very close apparently a lot of
kids died because they're not diagnosed
in time and then he said those words he
said there is no cure he said we think
we're about 10 to 15 years away from a
cure but then again we said that 15
years ago and I know many of you don't
have to imagine what that feels like
because you or someone you love has been
through something similar now in Ian's
case it was juvenile type 1 diabetes
there's nothing you can do to prevent
type 1 and once you have it it affects
every meal you eat every jog you take
every night sleep you have for the rest
of your life it dramatically complicates
every other disease you get for Ian at
school getting a cold or a flu from
another kid
it's actually a very serious affair and
Ian has to check in with the school
nurse four times every single day and if
you knew in if you knew him like I do
then you would be so so proud of the
amount of courage inside of that little
person every single day now I'm trained
as an economist but I love people and if
you know any economist you know that
those two don't always go together
Dean 11 in the backs laughing a bit
so for me
Ian raises a very important question
which is as a society what are the
binding constraints keeping us from
cures from making the deadly manageable
and making them manageable turrible
and I think the answer may surprise you
see I find that many of us imagine where
it cures come from to be something like
this some scientists with gray hair
somewhere with a chemistry set maybe
even something a bit like that and I
think I know where we get that from I
mean this is a real photo one of
Medicine's greatest hits the accidental
discovery of penicillin by Sir Alexander
Fleming but there's one problem that was
in 1928 do you think anything's changed
perhaps since then yes today we have a
process it's a process we trust and it
is long it is regulated it is
complicated and it moves science into
clinical trials and clinical trials into
medicine and if we want this process to
work if we want this scientists to have
the data that they need if we want
clinical trials to run on time if we
want patients to have safe and effective
medication time to be notified when
there's a cure for them then we need a
big big idea we need connected health
intelligence let me give you an example
so a couple of weeks ago I was reading a
blog post from Bill Gates he was writing
about Alzheimer's disease no no cure
today for Alzheimer's and he wrote the
number one barrier to a breakthrough in
Alzheimer's number one is a more
efficient way to recruit patients for
clinical trials earlier in the disease's
progression they need to find the right
patient at the right time and this isn't
just a problem for Alzheimer's today
we're running 10 times more clinical
trials than we were in the early 2000s
that's a huge increase in our ability to
find cures but over 80
cent of clinical trials can't recruit
enough patients on time so what's
keeping us from solving this matching
problem we solve matching problems all
day every day we solve it in
ride-hailing we solve it in Home Sharing
in song suggestions in matchmaking it's
not even that hard to imagine some sort
of Google search across all health
information but it doesn't exist
we don't have connected health
intelligence it's not for lack of data
health care is generating more data than
any other industry in the entire world
so what is it what is it that is keeping
the researchers trying to find cures the
doctors trying to prevent diseases
earlier in the progression the people
who are trying to save your life from
that data it's killing people and it is
a big big problem so what are we going
to do well the good news and there is
good news everyone there is goodness is
that the three major barriers the three
major barriers to connected health
intelligence have now been overcome so
I'm going to walk you through these
three and I think by the end you'll
agree that the future of healthcare is
going to look very different than it
does today those barriers were one
making health information digital 2 was
structuring the information and 3 the
hardest of all was preserving patient
privacy so let's walk through these
number one I want you to imagine the
clipboard the clipboard the enemy of all
progress in healthcare second only
perhaps to the fax machine so you know
what I'm talking about all of those
papers with the grimy little pen that
everyone else has coughed on and the
chain as though you'd want to take that
pen home you know what I'm talking about
that's going away now your health
information is digital this really
started accelerating about 10 years ago
and today 98% of hospitals are using
some
of electronic health records so that
brings us to number two health
information is digital but it's messy
and unstructured you can kind of imagine
it like millions and millions of free
texts doctor's notes in Word documents
but in order to make sense of it we need
it to look more like an Excel
spreadsheet with nice rows and columns
so what happened well it's the same
technology that powers your Siri and
your Alexa it's a branch of artificial
intelligence called natural language
processing and it's the way that
computers are able to turn text into
meaning and now it is so good that we
can scan those millions and millions of
documents and the highly technical
documents and get structured information
out of it which is just incredible but
that brings us to three and this has a
lot to do with you and me
this is patient privacy your health
records belong to you and mine belong to
me they do not belong to any insurance
company any Hospital any researcher and
as a society we've chosen to value
patient privacy above researchers need
for transparency so what happened well
just in the past few months there have
been breakthroughs in decentralized
private artificial intelligence and
first the fact in fact the first paper
that's going to be published on this
it's coming out in two days here at
Stanford with applications in medicine
so you're now all ahead of the curve
this gives researchers the ability to
ask questions and query information that
they don't otherwise have access to and
is distributed due to privacy concerns
so now with these building blocks we
have all three things we need for
connected health intelligence and I
think that it's going to change life for
you and for me and for people like in
one of the reasons why I relate so much
to Ian story is that in many ways it's
my own story when I was four years old
my parents Ian's grandparents heard the
words for your son there is no cure he
will live with a life-threatening
autoimmune disorder and I know
personally what it would have meant as a
kid to hear we have a cure to avoid
those painful moments of uncertainty
those close calls where I wasn't sure if
I was going to make it if I was going to
be an adult one day if I would be here
standing in front of you right now but
being sick has a way of really
clarifying for you what matters most and
why and I think that the words that my
kids will hear will be different I think
the words that my kids will hear will be
yes yes we have a cure thank you
[Applause]
[Music]